[ Music ]
JEAN-FRANÇOIS BILODEAU: Have
you ever been in the middle
of investigating an incident
with alerts piling up,
teammates asking for
update, and not enough time
to make sense of everything?
In security operation the
cause of a delay is real --
missed indicator,
incomplete triage,
and decision made
with a full context.
This learning path is designed
to help you turn that chaos
into clarity by showing you
how Microsoft Security Copilot
and its embedded experience
can accelerate investigations
and improve the quality
of your response.
Hello and welcome.
I'm glad you've joined us.
I'm Jean-François Bilodeau, a
Microsoft Technical Trainer.
In this session, we'll cover
Defend against cyber threat
with Microsoft's security
operation platform.
As part of Learning Path
2, let's get started
with Microsoft Security Copilot.
Here's the agenda for
this learning path.
We'll start with fundamentals
of generative AI
because that's the engine
behind today's Copilots.
Next, we'll describe how
Microsoft Security Copilot
and what it is and
why it matters.
Then we'll explore the
embedded experiences
where Copilot's
capabilities show
up directly inside Microsoft
Security products.
Finally, we'll look at
Security Copilot Agent
in Microsoft Defender,
which helps automate
and accelerate common SOC tasks.
To use Security Copilot well,
it helps to understand the
fundamental of generative AI.
Here we pivot into the basics,
what generative AI is,
the role of large language
model, where Azure OpenAI fits,
what Copilot means in practice,
and how prompt engineering
helps you get better results.
In this module, we'll explore
how large language model,
often called LLMs, enable
AI application and services
to generate original content
from natural language input.
We'll also connect that
idea to the emergence
of AI-powered Copilots, which
are designed to assist humans
with creative and
analytical tasks.
By the end of this
module, you'll be able
to describe what
generative AI is,
what large language models
are, what Azure OpenAI is,
what Copilots are, and how
to improve generative
AI responses using
prompt engineering.
We'll treat each of these
as building blocks,
and then you'll see
how they map directly
to real security workflow
later in the session.
Let's start by separating
two related ideas:
AI and generative AI.
AI imitates human behavior
by using machine learning
to interact with its
environment and execute tasks
without being explicitly
told exactly what the output
should be.
Generative AI is a
specific type of AI
that creates original content.
This is what powers many
modern chat application.
Generative AI application
takes natural language input
and return responses
in different format.
One common format is natural
language generation.
For example, you might
ask give me three ideas
for healthy breakfast,
including peppers,
and receive a clear,
written answer.
Another format is
image generation,
where requests might
create an image
of an elephant eating a burger
can result in a new image.
A third format is code
generation, where you might ask,
show me how to code a game
of tic-tac-toe with Python,
and the tool produces starter
code that you can refine.
A popular example of this kind
of application is ChatGPT,
a chat bot created by OpenAI,
an AI research company
that partners closely
with Microsoft.
The key point is that generative
AI isn't just automation.
It's content creation driven
by language understanding.
Generative AI
application are powered
by large language
models, or LLMs.
These are specialized machine
learning models designed
for natural language
processing tasks
that includes
determining sentiment
or classifying text more
broadly, summarizing text,
comparing multiple text sources
for semantic similarities,
and generating new
natural language.
Even though the math behind
LLM can get complex,
having a basic
conceptual understanding
of how they're built and
used makes it easier
to understand why Copilots
can be so helpful,
and why the way you ask
questions has a direct impact
on the quality of the output.
Now let's connect those
models to the cloud platform
where many organization
deploy them.
Azure OpenAI service is
Microsoft's cloud solution
for deploying, customizing, and
hosting large language models.
It brings together OpenAI
models and API with security,
scalability, and governance
you expect from Azure.
Azure OpenAI services include
pretrained generative AI models,
customization capabilities,
built-in tool to detect
and mitigate harmful use cases
so you can implement
AI responsibly,
an enterprise scale security
like role-based access control,
RBAC, and support
for private network.
And when it comes
to development,
you can build solution
using Azure AI Foundry,
the REST-API-supported
SDKs, or the Azure CLI.
Azure OpenAI supports
multiple-use cases
to serve different needs.
GPT-4o models are the
latest generation
for natural language
and code completion.
GPT-3.5 models like GPT-3.5
Turbo are optimized
for chat-based
interaction and work well
with many generative
AI solution.
Embedding model converts
text into numerical vectors,
which helps with
language-analytic tasks
like comparing text
for similarities.
And finally, we also have
DALL-E models, which are used
for image generation from
natural language prompts.
Developers can work with these
models in Azure AI Studio,
a web-based environment
where you can deploy, test,
and manage the models used for
generative AI apps deployment.
This is where you can
experiment in Chat Playground,
provide few-shot
example, and validate
that the model behavior matches
what your application needs.
The availability of large
language model has led
to a new category of computing
often referred to as Copilots.
Copilots are
typically integrated
in many existing application and
provide help with common tasks
by tapping into
generative AI models.
You've probably seen
this pattern already
where a chat panel open next to
your work and helps you draft,
summarize, or create
content using context
from the product
you're already in.
It's also useful to think about
the life cycle behind a Copilot.
First, huge amount
of data are used
to train a large language model.
Then services like Azure OpenAI
make those pretrained models
available, and developers
can use them as is,
or fine-tune them
with custom data.
Once a model is deployed,
it becomes available
for applications.
Developers then build Copilot
experiences that submit prompts
to the model and shape the
output of real workflow.
And finally, business
users use those Copilots
to boost productivity
and creativity,
helping with first draft,
synthesizing information,
supporting planning,
and so much more.
Next, let's focus on something
that directly affects
your day-to-day success
with any Copilot:
prompt engineering.
Prompt engineering is the
process of creating prompts
to get better outcomes, and
it isn't only for developers.
Anyone using a generative
AI application can improve
responses quality by using clear
language setting expectation,
providing examples,
and grounding the requests
in relevant data.
One technique is direct
language, being explicit
about the type of
response you want.
For example, create a
list of 10 things to do
in Edinburgh during August.
Another technique is
using system messages,
where you describe how the
assistant should pass,
such as you're a helpful
assistant that responds
in a cheerful, friendly manner.
You also provide example.
Even though LLMs can respond
with zero-shot learning,
meaning without example, you
can get more consistent result
with one-shot or
few-shot learning
by giving it a sample response
like visit the castle
in the morning before
the cloud arrive,
and letting the model
continue with that style.
Finally, grounding data
gives the model context
so that it can generate
a more accurate output.
For instance, if you want
a summary of an email,
include the email
text in a prompt
and ask the model
to summarize it.
Overall, the quality of a
response depends not only
on the model, but also how
you communicate your goal
and constraints, so clear,
specific prompt makes a
measurable difference.
Let's quickly summarize
what we've covered
in this first module.
Generative AI is typically
built into software application
and uses large language model
trained on huge volumes of text
to generate human-like natural
language responses and,
in some cases, even
original images.
You now have the essentials:
what generative AI is,
what large language model
do, what Azure OpenAI is,
what Copilots are, and how
prompt engineering helps you
improve the response
that you get.
Now we'll shift from
the AI foundation
into the security-specific
focus of this learning path:
Microsoft Security Copilot.
Here, we'll get acquainted
with what it is, how it works,
the terminology you'll see
throughout the product,
and what it takes to enable
it in an organization.
In this module,
you'll get acquainted
with Microsoft Security Copilot.
We'll start with the
basic terminology,
then walk through how Security
Copilot processes prompt,
what makes a prompt effective,
and how to enable the solution
so users can begin
working with it.
By the end, you'll be able
to describe what Microsoft
Security Copilot is,
explain key Security
Copilot terminology,
explain how it processes prompt
request, identify the element
of an effective prompt,
and describe how
to enable Microsoft Security
Copilot in your organization.
Microsoft Security
Copilot is an AI-powered,
cloud-based security analysis
tool that helps analysis
like us respond to threats
quickly, process signal
at machine speed, and
access risk, expose faster
than may otherwise be possible.
In other words, it's
designed to help you move
from raw security data to
actionable understanding
without losing time
on manual synthesis.
Security Copilot combines
powerful large language model
with security-specific
models from Microsoft.
It integrates Microsoft
and non-Microsoft sources,
and it learns at machine speed
to help analysts identify
and respond to emerging threats.
Just as importantly,
enterprise data is protected
by comprehensive enterprise
compliance and security control,
so you can apply AI assistance
without compromising
governance expectation.
Now let's take a look
at the core use cases
of Security Copilot.
It's designed to make easy.
One common scenario is
incident summarization,
using generative AI to
distill complex alert
into concise,
actionable summaries.
This helps you gain context
quickly and communicate clearly
across your organization, which
can lead to faster response
and better decision-making.
Another scenario is
impact analysis,
where AI-driven analytics helps
you assess the potential impact
of an incident, highlighting
affected system and data
so you can prioritize
response efforts.
A third scenario is reverse
engineering of scripts.
Instead of manually
unpacking complex
or obfuscated
command-line scripts,
Copilot can translate the
script into natural language
and explain what action
are being performed,
while also helping you extract
and link indicator found
in the script to entities
in your environment.
Finally, guided responses
provide step-by-step
recommendation for triage,
investigation, containment,
and remediation,
often with deep links
to help you take actions faster.
Let's take a look at how you can
experience Security Copilot.
One way is through the
standalone experience available
through a dedicated site.
In this experience, you interact
through the prompt bar,
submitting requests
and natural language,
and Copilot returns output
aspects, image, or documents.
It's also important
to contrast this
with the embedded experience,
where Copilot's capabilities are
placed directly inside Microsoft
Security Products.
We'll explore that next because
embedded Copilot is often
where analysis starts,
right where the investigation
is already happening.
Some Microsoft product
like Microsoft Defender XDR
embeds Copilot directly
into the user interface.
In defender XDR, areas
such as incident
and advanced hunting
are examples
of where the embedded
Copilot can show up.
The idea is simple.
You don't have to leave
the tool you're already
in to start using
AI-assisted summaries,
guidance, or analysis.
You start where you are, and
Copilot helps you move faster.
Before you start writing prompt,
let's align on a few terms
you'll see throughout
Security Copilot.
A session is a particular
conversation within Copilot,
and Copilot maintains
context within that session.
A prompt is a specific statement
or question inside the session
entered through the prompt bar.
A capability is a function
Copilot uses to solve part
of a problem, and you may
also hear capability referred
to as skills.
A plugin is a collection
of capabilities provided
by a particular resource,
like Microsoft Intune,
and the orchestrator
is Copilot system
for composing those capabilities
together to answer your prompt.
at the center of the
experience is the prompt bar.
You use it to tell Copilot
what insights you want
from your security data.
Behind the scene, Copilot
integrates with various sources
through plugins, including
Microsoft Security product
such as Microsoft Sentinel,
Microsoft Defender XDR,
Microsoft Intune, as well
as non-Microsoft solution
and Open Source
Intelligence feed.
For each data source, the plugin
brings a set of capabilities,
each one designed to
perform a specialized task
within that product scope.
Here's a concrete example.
The plugin for Microsoft
Defender XDR supports capability
such as analyzing a file,
generating an incident report,
generating guided
response, listing incident
and related alerts, as well
as summarizing the security
state of a device.
When you ask a question,
the orchestrator can choose
and combine these capabilities
so the response isn't just
some generic text answer.
It's grounded in your
security tooling and data.
Now let's make
prompt-writing practical.
Security analysts
and researchers should
include four elements
when writing an effective
prompt: the goal, the context,
the expectation, and the source.
Your goal is the specific
security-related information
you need.
Context explain why you need
it or how you'll use it.
Expectation defines the
format or target audience,
like whether you want bullet
points, a short summary,
or a report written
for executives.
And source is the known
information data source
or plugin Copilot should use.
As you write prompt, keep
a few things in mind.
Be specific and concise.
Iterate. Try alternative
version of your prompt
if the first response
isn't quite what you need.
Provide necessary context to
narrow down where Copilot looks.
Give positive instruction
instead of focusing on what not
to do and directly
address Copilot as you
to make the request
clear and actionable.
Now let's walk
through what it takes
to enable Microsoft
Security Copilot
to start using the service
organization onboard both the
service and the user.
Practically, you navigate to
the Security Copilot site,
choose an Azure
subscription, and choose
or create a secure
resource group.
Then you provision Copilot
capacity by naming your capacity
and adding at least 1 SCU,
security compute unit.
After that, you set up
the default environment
and assign the appropriate
role permission.
Each of these steps is
explored in more details next.
Before anyone can begin using
Copilot, Administrators need
to provision and
allocate capacity.
You must have an
Azure subscription,
and you must be an Azure owner,
or at least an Azure contributor
at the resource group level.
One important nuance is
that Global Administrators
aren't automatically Azure
owners or contributor
by default.
That access can be configured
in the Azure portal.
There are two ways to
provision capacity.
You can provision capacity
within Security Copilot,
which is the
recommended approach,
or you can provision capacity
through the Azure portal.
Once capacity is in place,
Security Copilot also provides
a usage monitoring dashboard
for capacity owners, so
you can track consumption
and manage how
capacity is allocated.
After provisioning capacity, you
set up the default environment.
To do that, you'll need one
of the following Microsoft Entra
ID role, Global Administrator,
or Security Administrator.
During setup, you're prompted
to configure several settings,
including how much SCU,
security compute unit,
capacity to allocate and
the geographic location
of your tenant because
customer data collected
by the service is
stored in that region.
Security Copilot operates
in Azure Data Center
in multiple regions,
including the European Union,
United Kingdom, United States,
Australia, New Zealand, Japan,
Canada, South America.
You can also decide
whether to opt in or opt
out of data-sharing option
for product improvements.
For example, you can allow
Microsoft to capture data
from Security Copilot
and validate product
performance using human review
or allow capture and human
review to help build
and validate Microsoft
Security AI model.
Importantly, opting in
doesn't allow Microsoft
to use customer data to
train foundational model.
Another key setting controls
whether Security Copilot can
access data from your
Microsoft 365 services.
If this option is turned off,
your organization
can't use plugins
that accesses Microsoft
365 services.
And currently this
option is required
for using the Microsoft
Purview plugin.
Challenging it requires a user
with a Global
Administrator role.
Now let's clarify permission.
You can assign access using
Microsoft Entra ID role
or Security Copilot role,
and a best practice is
to use the least-privileged role
that still enables the
work someone needs to do.
Microsoft Entra role like
Global Administrators,
Security Administrators,
Security Operator,
and Security Reader,
apply beyond Copilot,
so they grant broader
permission across the tenant.
To keep Copilot access more
targeted Security Copilot also
introduces two roles that
function like access groups,
but are managed within
Copilot itself: Copilot owner
and Copilot contributor.
These roles grant access only
to Security Copilot features.
The Security Administrator and
Global Administrator roles
in Microsoft Entra automatically
inherit Copilot owner access,
and by default, all user and the
Entra tenant are given Copilot
contributor access,
meaning any user
with a licensed tenant
can create sessions
and run prompt unless an
admin restricts what access
by removing all users from the
workspace contributor assignment
and replacing it with a
specific security group.
One more nuance, Copilot doesn't
go beyond the access you've
already have.
Even if you can open
Copilot and create prompt,
individual plugins may
require additional
product-specific role.
For example, to use
Microsoft Sentinel plugin,
you need a sentinel role,
like reader to access
incident in the workspace.
To use the Intune plugin
for devices and policy,
you need an
Intune-specific role,
such as an Endpoint
Security Manager.
In many cases, Microsoft plugin
uses an on-behalf-of model.
Copilot, recognizes licensing
and signs into product
on your behalf, whether
the plugin is enabled,
while some plugin
requires extra setup
and parameter for
authentication.
Let's summarize this module.
Microsoft Security
Copilot is an AI-powered,
cloud-based security
analysis tool designed
to help organization meet
the growing challenge
of cybersecurity.
You'll learn what Security
Copilot is, key terminology,
how prompt requests are
processed through plugins
and capabilities, what
makes a prompt effective,
and the practical steps to
enable Security Copilot,
including capacity, environment
setup, and the role permissions.
Next, we'll focus on
embedded experiences
where a Security Copilot
is accessible directly
from Microsoft Security product.
This matters because it
brings AI assistant right
into the investigator's
workflow,
reducing context-switching
and enabling faster decision.
Microsoft Security Copilot
is accessible directly
through some Microsoft Security
product, and that's what we mean
by the embedded experience.
In this module, we'll take a
look at the scenario supported
by the embedded experience in
Microsoft Security solution.
By the end of this
module, you'll be able
to describe Microsoft Copilot
in Microsoft Defender XDR,
Microsoft Purview,
and Microsoft Entra.
Here we bring the embedded
concept into focus.
Microsoft Security Copilot
is accessible directly
from some Microsoft Security
product such as Defender XDR,
Microsoft Entra, and Purview,
with more integration coming.
In the embedded experience,
Copilot invokes product-specific
capabilities directly,
which can improve
processing efficiency
because the right tool
and context are immediately
available to Security Copilot.
The embedded experience
is also a great place
to start a security
investigation,
and when you need a deeper
cross-product investigation,
you can seamlessly transition
to the standalone experience
to bring in all the Copilot
capabilities enabled
for your role.
To use an embedded experience,
the Microsoft plugin
for that solution
must be enabled,
and the user must have
permission to access Copilot,
plus any additional
permission required
to access the underlying
product and data.
Let's take a look
at a key example.
Security Copilot embeds in
Microsoft Defender XDR.
This integration is designed to
help security team investigate
and respond to incidents
quickly and efficiently.
Within Defender XDR, Copilot
can support capabilities
such as summarizing events,
providing guided responses,
analyzing scripts,
translating natural language
into KQL queries for
advanced hunting,
generating incident
reports, analyzing file,
and summarizing devices.
When you need to understand
an incident fast,
Copilot in Defender XDR can
generate an incident summary.
Copilot creates an
overview of the attack
that helps you quickly
understand what happened,
what assets are involved, and
the timeline of the attack.
In fact, Copilot automatically
creates a summary
when you navigate to
an incident page.
Incidents containing up to
100 alerts can be summarized
into a single incident summary.
Depending on the data available,
that summary can include
when the attack started,
where it started --
meaning the entity
or asset involved --
a timeline of how the attack
unfolded, the assets involved,
indicator of compromise,
and even the name
of threat actors involved.
The value is immediate.
You spend less time
reading raw alert detail
and more time making
informed-response decision.
Another powerful capability
is guided responses.
Copilot in Defender XDR uses
AI and machine learning
to contextualize an
incident and learn
from previous investigation,
generating appropriate response
action you can follow.
This helps incident
response team
at all level apply response
actions confidently and quickly.
Guided response are
organized into categories.
Triage includes recommendation
for classifying incidents
as informational, true
positive, false positive.
Containment provides action
to contain the incident.
Investigation suggests next
step to gather more evidence,
and remediation, focuses
on response action applied
to specific entities
involved in the incident.
Each guided response
card includes details
like why the action
is recommended,
and may include options such
as viewing similar incident,
helping you learn from patterns
across your environments.
For remediation actions, team
can also view user information
when steps like password
reset are required.
Many sophisticated attack,
including ransomware, use script
and PowerShell to
evade detection,
and dual scripts are
often obfuscated,
making analysis low
and error-prone.
Copilot's script
analysis capability
in Defender XDR helps
reduce that friction
by letting you inspect
script and code
without relying
on external tool.
You can access script analysis
from the alert timeline
within an incident specifically
for timeline entries
that includes a script or code
such as PowerShell.exe event.
Copilot support
scripts languages
like PowerShell, Batch, Bash.
The outcome is
faster understanding
of what the script is doing
and quicker determination
of whether it's
malicious or benign.
Threat-hunting often requires
writing KQL queries,
and that can be a barrier if
you're new to the language
or you're trying
to move quickly.
Copilot in Defender XDR includes
a query-assistant capability
in advanced hunting that
reduces the time it takes
to write hunting
queries from scratch.
You can generate a KQL query
from a suggested prompt,
or you can enter your own
prompt in natural language,
like asking for all alerts
involving a specific user.
Copilot then generates
the KQL query aligned
to the advanced query schema.
From there, you can run the
query directly or insert it
in the editor to refine it, save
it, share it, or run it later.
This frees you to focus on
investigating threats instead
of wrestling with the syntax.
Here we shift from
investigation to documentation.
In Microsoft Defender XDR,
Copilot can generate a
full incident report
with just a single action.
By selecting the ellipsis or the
report icon, you can ask Copilot
to generate an incident report
that consolidates everything
that happened during the
incident life cycle.
That includes key timestamp for
incident management actions,
the analysts involved
in the response,
how the incident was classified,
and the investigation
and remediation action
that were taken.
It also captures
follow-up action,
recommendation, and next steps.
While an incident summary
gives you a fast overview
of what happened, an incident
report provides a comprehensive,
auditable record that brings
together analyst-driven steps,
automated action, and supported
context from across Defender XDR
and Microsoft Sentinel.
Let's take a look at how Copilot
helps with file analysis.
Sophisticated attacks
often rely on files
that closely mimic legitimate or
system files to avoid detection.
Copilot in Microsoft Defender
XDR enables security team
to quickly identify
suspicious or malicious file
without manually digging
into raw details.
When you analyze a file,
Copilot produces an overview
that assesses the file's
behavior and risk level,
along with a detailed
section that includes things
like embedded strings, API call,
and relevant certificates.
This allows analysts to move
quickly from uncertainty
to clarity and decide whether
the file represents a
real threat.
Another valuable capability
is device summarization.
Copilot can generate
a concise summary
of a device security posture,
including vulnerable software,
exposure level, and
any unusual behavior
that have been observed.
Security analysts can
use this device summary
to accelerate investigation
by understanding
the broader context
of a device involved
in an incident.
Whether accessed directly
from the incident assets view
or from the device
overview page,
the summary helps team quickly
determine whether a device
represents a larger risk
to the environment.
Across all these
Defender XDR feature,
there's a few capabilities
that remain consistent.
One is feedback.
Just like the
standalone experience,
the embedded experience allows
you to provide feedback
on AI-generated responses,
whether they look accurate,
off target, or potentially
inappropriate.
This feedback helps improve
the overall quality
and reliability of
Copilot responses.
Another shared capability
is the ability to move
from the embedded experience
into the standalone experience.
The embedded Copilot is a great
place to start an investigation,
especially when you're already
working inside the vendor XDR.
If your investigation expands
and requires deeper
cross-product analysis,
you can seamlessly transition
into the standalone experience
and continue with the full set
of Copilot capabilities
enabled for your role.
Now let's introduce
another powerful extension
of Copilot Security: Copilot
agents and Microsoft Defender.
These agents are available
through the security store
in the Defender portal and
are designed to help automate
and accelerate common
security operation task.
In the Microsoft
defender portal.
The security store offers
a growing collection
of agents published by
Microsoft and partners.
These agents integrate directly
into Microsoft Defender
and perform tasks such as
incident triage, investigation,
threat-hunting, and
threat intelligence.
Each agent is purpose-built
to reduce manual effort
and helps SOC team
operate more efficiently.
By the end of this
module, you'll be able
to describe the Security
Copilot AI agents available
in Microsoft Defender
and understand how they
support real-world security
operation workflow.
Let's take a closer look at the
agents currently available.
To purchase and deploy custom
agent from the security store,
you need access to the Security
Copilot workspace provisioned
with SCU capability.
The phishing triage agent helps
security analysts automatically
triage and classify
user-submitted
phishing incident.
It operates autonomously
and is triggered
when a user reports
phishing emails.
The agent requires Microsoft
Defender for Endpoint Plan 2
and Security Administrator
permission to configure.
The threat-intelligence briefing
agent provides regular,
customized threat-intelligence
briefing by gathering
and synthesizing information
from multiple sources.
It runs autonomously and
helps teams stay focused
about relevant threat
without manual research.
The threat-hunting
agents assist analysts
with end-to-end threat-hunting
using natural language.
It not only generates
KQL queries,
but also interprets
results, surfaces insight,
and guides analysts through
a complete hunting session.
Finally, the Dynamics Threat
Detection agent is an always-on
backend service that
continuously looks
for hidden threats across
Defender and Microsoft Sentinel.
It uses AI to correlate
alerts, events, anomaly,
and threat intelligence
to uncover false negative
and detection gaps.
Here we focus on the phishing
triage agent in action.
Once deployed, this agent
automatically evaluates
user-submitted phishing
messages, analyzes indicators,
and classifies the incident.
By offloading routine phishing
analysis to an autonomous agent,
SOC team can reduce alert
fatigue and focus their time
on higher-impact investigation.
And now let's take a moment and
see Security Copilot in action.
Let's take a look
at a demo together.
In this demo, let's set up
Microsoft Security Copilot.
First thing we're
going to have to do
over here is grant an
Administrator the necessary
privileges to manage
the service itself.
So we're going to set up
permissions in Azure to do that.
Let's get started.
We're in the Azure
portal right now.
We're going to open up
Entra ID, and in Entra ID,
let's go down to
"Manage" and turn
on "Access management
for Azure resources."
We're going to do that
for Howard Avery --
-- and we're done.
Let's go back out of
the Azure portal,
and let's select our
subscription to ensure
that Howard Avery now has the
necessary permission not just
to manage Entra ID,
but also to set
up configure Security Copilot.
So from the subscription,
we're going to click
on "Access control (IAM),"
Identity and Access Management,
and let's set up a
role assignment.
Let's "Add a role assignment."
Which role?
We're going to need a Privileged
Administrator role for that one,
so let's give Avery
Howard the owner role.
This is a very permissive role.
So as always, if you can
use a less permissive role,
the better.
Next, let's select who
is part of that role.
Normally, we would select a
group, but for that demo,
I'm going to select a user.
Let's go with Avery Howard
once again, and we're going
to give Avery Howard full
privilege with that role,
"Allow user to assign
all role except
privileged administrator."
So we're just going to
remove that privilege,
but Avery Howard has every
other administrative permission
available to him at this point.
We're pretty much done.
So now let's set up the capacity
for Microsoft Security Copilot.
We've already granted Avery
Howard the necessary privileges
to do so.
Now, as Avery, let's start
by selecting the Azure
subscription we want to use,
the resource group and where we
want to provision the service.
We'll give the capacity a name.
We'll stick with the default.
And where do you want
to provision it?
We're going to select United
States for this demo.
But if the region becomes busy,
we are going to allow Copilot
to spill into other
regions as well.
If this is not acceptable,
if Copilot must stay
within your region,
whatever that might be,
then don't select that option.
Capacity region US East
is selected for us.
And finally, how many units
do we want to provision?
Let's start with one, and this
is something we can adjust
after the fact.
Finally, we can also
turn on dynamic users,
so use coverage
unit when needed.
If we exceed our
one unit capacity,
we can now start using
capacity on demand,
$6 US per unit as we need them.
This is something you can turn
on or off at your leisure.
And finally, when it
comes to on-demand unit,
do we want to cap it, or do
we want to let Copilot scale
to whatever level is necessary?
Let's accept and acknowledge
that we understand the terms
and condition and start
provisioning the capacity.
Do we want to send
telemetry to Microsoft?
I'll let you choose.
Your information is never
used to train the model.
As is mentioned over
here, we never,
ever use our client information
to train our AI model.
Finally, do you want to
integrate Microsoft Purview
in your Security Copilot?
Might as well.
And let's also grant access
to our users that are part
of security group, standard
security group, in Purview,
Entra ID, and Azure, to be able
to use the Security
Copilot as well.
Let's turn on recommended
Microsoft Security roles.
Let's "Continue."
And we're set.
We've provisioned
Security Copilot,
and now we're ready
to start using it.
We're going to take a look at
the interactive experience.
Then we'll also take a look
at the embedded experience.
Before we start using the
interactive experience,
we can see that Security
Copilot gives us prompts
for us to explore.
Let's go to the hamburger button
in the upper-left corner.
There's a number of goodies
in here I'd like to explore
with you before we get started.
There's your home link.
There's your session.
Any conversation that you have
with Security Copilot
will be saved,
and you can go back
to them at any time.
From here, we also have
the promptbook library,
which are free-build
prompts that you can use,
and you can define your own
promptbook to execute a sequence
of prompt, a series of prompt,
and we can parameterize
our promptbooks as well.
We'll see an example
later, but for now,
let's go into our settings.
These are our personal settings.
Here's the number of secure
compute unit we're using,
the name, the capacity we set
up earlier, our subscription,
our resource group, and we can
change those if necessary.
We're not going to do
that in this demo.
There's our total
compute unit, and again,
we can change that if necessary.
We can also turn on and
off whether or not we want
to send telemetry to
Microsoft and whether
or not we want Security Copilot
to be integrated with Purview.
Let's keep things as is.
Finally down below,
who can upload files
to Security Copilot?
Right now we've got no
one can upload files.
We'll leave it as is.
Next, "plugins."
This is where you get a lot
of your power out of Copilot.
You can enable or disable a
variety of plugins over here.
Right now, we've only
got accessing data
from Microsoft 365 services.
It's not turned on,
but we can turn it
on with a single click,
and we're good to go.
We can also control who
can manage the plugins.
For now, we'll leave
it as owner only.
Role assignment, who has
access to Security Copilot?
Right now we've got three role
who has access to
Security Copilot.
We can add additional
member or simply click
on "Add recommended
role," at a click.
This will add everybody in
Entra ID role, Purview role,
and Defender role that
deal with security.
They will now have access
to Security Copilot.
Let's take a look at
usage monitoring.
This is important over here.
You want to get the best
value out of Copilot.
So how used is the service based
on the capacity
that we provision?
Who uses the service?
We can see over here the users
and how much they have made
use of Security Copilot.
And let's take a look
in our settings.
This is for our comfort and
convenience, the theme we want
to use, the workspace we're
working against, language --
you want to work in
French, English,
whatever language you want.
Here's our privacy statement,
and again, I want to reaffirm
that we do not use
your information
to improve our AI services.
All right, let's
go back to home,
and let's actually
use Security Copilot.
We've got a number of
prompts we can try.
Down below, there's
the prompt box.
This is where you can enter
your natural language
prompts queries.
It uses generative AI.
It uses large language models,
so there's no form or structure
that you're expected
to use in your prompt.
Express yourself using natural
language, and take a look
at the predefined prompt
to get ideas of the type
of interaction, natural
language interaction,
we can have with
Security Copilot.
For example, here's a prompt.
What group is app
name assigned to?
What are the critical
Sentinel incident right now?
We can click on those.
If we select, for example, what
group is app name assigned to,
app name would be a parameter.
We would enter the name of
the app we want to look at.
All right, let's open
up a prompt book.
Let's see promptbooks in action.
Here, a promptbook
is a collection
of predefined prompt
that will execute.
They're usually parameterized.
In this case, I would specify
the name of an actor,
and then every single
prompt that we see
in that promptbook
would be executed,
and we'll see an example
of that later on.
There's a number of promptbooks.
I highly encourage
you to explore those.
They're categorized by
roles like SOC Analyst,
IT Administrator, Data
Security Administrator.
This will filter
your promptbooks.
And going back to sessions.
This is very valuable.
If you are handling multiple
cases at once, don't put them
on the same conversation;
start new session.
Let's open a previous session.
Here's the conversation
that we had
with Security
Copilot previously,
where we asked what are the
last three failed login?
And we can see the last
three failed logins,
starting with Gebhard over here.
Same user again and
same user again,
three times the user
failed to log in.
And now we're going to
ask what are the UPNs
for the failed login?
And Copilot gives us
a nice bulleted list
of those user principal names.
So use natural
language, ask question,
get it to generate
a response for you.
And from there, you can put
those in a spreadsheet.
You can ask Copilot to give you
a table, to give you bullet,
to give you whatever
output you'd like to use.
This has been an overview
of the interactive experience
of Security Copilot.
Now let's take a look
at the embedded experience
of Security Copilot.
So we looked at the interactive
Copilot experience.
Now let's flip things
around and take a look
at the embedded experience,
where now Copilot kicks
in automatically when you're
doing your investigation,
when you're working in Defender.
Let's take a look at an incident
that we have over here.
Human-operated ransomware
attack was launched.
That is concerning.
Let's do a little bit
of investigation.
As we open the incident,
notice on our right.
Copilot comes in and immediately
provides a nice summary
of the incident.
There it is.
I'm not going to read through
the whole thing, but very handy,
including the attack story,
as well as suggestion on how
to triage it, what to do
with our users, the entities
that encountered compromise over
here, like contact this user,
classify this incident.
For now, we'll just mark the
incident as "Completed,"
and let's continue to use
the embedded experience
to see what Copilot
can do for us.
We're going to take a
look at a specific alert,
"Suspicious RDP session," and as
we select the alert, once again,
Copilot kicks in and provides
a nice alert summary,
including the concerning lateral
movement we're seeing over here.
Let's take a look at the
alert in more detail.
We're going to open
up the Alert page.
We can see the process tree.
We can see the device
that was involved.
Let's use Copilot to provide
a summary of that device.
Here we go.
Let's expand it, and
here's the summary
that was provided
to us by Copilot.
We'll close it.
We can do the same with the
user account, Jonathan Wolcott.
Let's summarize their
information, and once again,
there it is, coming
straight from Copilot.
Let's close that, and let's take
a look at the process tree,
see what triggered the alert.
We'll expand it, scroll
down a little bit and, ooh,
there's some PowerShell
stuff going on over here.
We can see that PowerShell
executed a script.
That kind of concerns me.
That's an end-user machine.
Why would they be executing
a PowerShell script?
Here's the script
that got executed.
Now, if you know how to
read partial code, cool.
If you don't know how to read
partial code, not a problem.
Let's get Copilot to
analyze the script for us.
Here it is in plain
English for us
to review step-by-step
what the script does.
And what's beautiful
over here is even
if the script was obfuscated,
Copilot would de-obfuscate it
for us, explain to
us what it does,
if there is any
concerning activities.
Here it is line by line,
explained by Copilot.
We can see the lines
of the script,
and we can also see the MITRE
techniques that were used
in the script, things
like native API call.
Or below that, we've got a
system information discovery.
So I don't need to be
able to read the script.
Copilot does the heavy lifting
for me, so me at my end
as a Security Operation Analyst,
I can now properly action
and investigate that incident.
Another thing Copilot can help
us with is understand files,
not just scripts, but files
that might have been
used in the attack.
Let's take a look at that.
Let's crack "Evidence and
Response" open, "Files."
These are suspicious files
on the user's machine,
starting with mimikatz.
What the heck is mimikatz?
Well, let's crack it open,
and let's get Copilot
to explain it to us.
Let's click on the ellipsis --
-- print the file, and
generating a file analysis,
and Copilot tells us the file,
mimikatz.exe has been
detected, and it is a malware.
It is a tool that is used
to circumvent security
capture information.
Copilot gives us that.
So let's continue
our investigation.
Now let's do a bit of KQL.
Whether you're a KQL guru,
or you're entirely new,
let's switch over to the
interactive Security
Copilot experience.
And what we're going to do
over here is we're going
to ask Copilot to help us
further with that investigation,
using conversational
plain language over here.
So instead of us having to
figure everything out ourselves,
let's use a promptbook to
kickstart our investigation.
We're going to use the
Microsoft 365 Defender
incident investigation.
There's one parameter
we need to provide,
and that's the
Defender incident ID.
That was 185856, if I
remember correctly, "Submit."
Now Security Copilot in the
interactive experience will pull
up all the details that I need
to investigate that incident.
There it is, lots of
actionable detail,
still parsing through it.
Now, I'm seeing some really
interesting stuff in here,
stuff I want to make
sure I keep an eye on.
So I'll select the result,
and I'll pin them,
so now they're available on
the right side over here.
I can pin evidence and
information that's related
to my investigation and share
that evidence with my team
as well, so we can
work collaboratively
to handle this incident.
I'm not going to
share it right now,
but there's the "Share"
button for you.
And finally, let's use
Security Copilot to help us
with our query,
help us with KQL.
KQL requires a bit of
specialized knowledge to be able
to write a query, and we
are going to take a look
at KQL later on in this course.
But for now, let's get Copilot
to help us generate a KQL
query using natural language.
There we go.
Based on the incident, create
a query to proactively hunt
for the type of malware attack.
Let's submit the prompt --
-- and let's get Copilot to
generate a query for us.
Shouldn't take too, too long.
And there we go.
Here is the query that
Copilot generated
for us, fully documented.
It may seem intimidating.
If you want ask Copilot to
explain it to you further,
line by line, but for
now, let's try it out.
Let's go to "Hunting," or
let's just go to logs.
Drop into query that
was generated for us
by Copilot and run it.
And here's our results.
So we're able to generate
a sophisticated query
without having to write a
single line of KQL code.
If you need further
detail on the query,
you need follow-up query,
you need to understand
or change the query, go back
to the interactive Copilot
experience and get Copilot
to help you modify your
query, add to it, modify --
whatever you need to do.
Now that we've seen
the interactive
and embedded experience
of Security Copilot,
we've seen how we can use
generative AI in our workflow
to help us action and
understand events, alerts,
incidents in Sentinel.
Let's wrap up Learning Path 2.
In this learning path,
you explored how Microsoft
Security Copilot is accessible
directly from Microsoft
Security product
through embedded experiences.
You learned how to describe
Microsoft Security Copilot
in Microsoft Defender
XDR, Microsoft Purview,
and Microsoft Entra, and how
these integration helps security
team investigate and respond
to threats more efficiently.
This concludes our session.
There's many ways to continue
your learning journey.
We encourage you to watch other
videos in this course or search
out your next favorite topic on
Microsoft Learn at aka.ms/Learn.